あのね、みんなコーラ好きでしょ？
ね？
ママね　たくちゃんがね　コーラ好きだからね
今日はね　君たちのためにね
コーラが出るね　蛇口をね　作ろうと思うんだよね
おふざけは、ここまでだ
俺は今日、夢のマシンを作る
まぁ　あれですよ
よく蛇口から捻ってさコーラが出るってさ
みんなの夢だと思うんだよね
なんで今日は、実際に作ってみようと思います
準備するものはね
まずは、耐圧ホース
蛇口
バスポンプ
このケースにコーラを入れて
ポンプをここに入れて
コーラを吸い上げて
蛇口から、こう捻って出すみたいな
まぁ　うまくいけばいいんですけどね
まぁ　実際に作ってみましょう
まさか、人生で蛇口を買う日が来るなんて思ってもなかったよ
とりあえず蛇口にホースをつけましょい
俺これ、昔からの夢だったんだよね　もう
いつも水道から出る液体は、透明のものばかり
あっ　　取れちゃった
うあー　ばっぱっぱ
使う器具を間違えなく間違えちゃったな
全然くっつかないもん　これ
無理だよ　絶対つかないよ　こんなの
これまじで言ってんの
先にポンプ作っちまおう
これ俺できなかったらさ　ちょっとやばいんだけど
今後のYouTube生活に支障が出るぐらいやる気がなくなる
おっ！　きたきたきた
ポンプの行き先を蛇口にすればいいわけだ
結局な　ホースと蛇口がつなげないと、何も始まんないことがわかった
これとこれがほんとに、くっつかない
もう　これでよくねー？
誰か蛇口回して
もし今このままこれオンにしてここにいれると、
こっから出てくるってわけっしょ？
え・・・
あ、これちげーわ　電源だ　間違えた
これ電源だ　これ入れちゃダメだなんだ　間違えた間違えた
これ電源だ　俺ダメだ　こっち入れちゃ
完全に間違えた
オーケー　オーケー　アンダースタンド　アンダースタンド
（ok ok　understand   understand）
これでこうすると
これどうやって繋げればいいの　まじで
何とか出来ました
ホースとこれが繋げたんで
ポンプでコーラを巻き上げてるんで、もう少々お待ちください
いろいろ試したんですけど
やはり力だけでは
どうにもならないこともあります
多分ポンプの力が弱いのと、
炭酸だから、うまいことホースにコーラが来なくて
おっ！！！！
えへ
一応水っていうのは、
高いところから落ちてくるんで
一応これで、落ちてきているはずなので、
捻れば出ると思います
では、いきます
たのみます
あっ！　あっ！　やば！　きた！・・・
来た　来てる
やった　やった　見て
出た〜〜〜〜
まじで捻ったら出るんすよ
ほら
あー　べっちゃべちゃだけどいいや（床）
出るぞ　出るぞ・・・
やったーーー！！！！！
こういう固定とかしたら、完全にもう給水場ですからね
出てくるよー　出てるよ
おいおいおい・・・
っていうわけで、
あのー
実用的では、ありません！